wann sind wir endlich da zusammen sind
wir da etwas größer aus
[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen zu einem neuen
blog und ich begrüße euch komischerweise
immer in der küche gibt's doch gar nicht
also wer hätte sie weiter
10 uhr 21 ich habe noch nichts
gefrühstückt ich habe noch kein kaffee
getrunken das heißt ich muss mich jetzt
beeilen und ich bin einfach so müde
waren gestern noch bis halb drei war für
unbedingt ein ganz spezielles video
herausbringen wollte nämlich dass für
die dp chs und das war der wunsch ist
für das schnellst möglich machen diese
typische disney pixar ich hoffe jetzt
dass das video gut ankommt ich werde
gleich mal reinschauen und dann gehe ich
auf eure kommentare 1
[Musik]
habe ich mich frisch gemacht mich
umgezogen und jetzt keine tag starten
ich möchte euch jetzt aber unbedingt
meine möbel zeigen ich bekomme auf
install an ganz oft die nachricht auf
instagram seht ihr halt ein bisschen
mehr als sie auf youtube auf youtube ist
es immer nur die eine ecke in der küche
und auf instagram sieht man halt den
ganzen raum und viele wissen ja schon
was bei mir wohnen küche in einem ist es
ist eine wohnküche quasi wir halten uns
auch wirklich zu 90 prozent hier auch
ergänzen diese zehn prozent sind die wir
meinen part sind oder nach zeit schwach
ich zeig euch jetzt möbel die sind
übrigens von wave er da kam die
nachfrage auch ganz oft ob ich zufrieden
weil ja des service ist bombastisch und
die angegebenen lieferzahlen die stimme
doch man kann sich total darauf
einstellen und das perfekte für mich
wahre uns ist halt so ein ganz
spezielles maß ganz wichtig gewesen und
da konnte man online bei valve ganz
einfach suchen aber ich rede nicht viel
drumherum ich zeige es euch jetzt und
dann könnt ihr selber sehen also das ist
unser sofa und das ist so bequem ihr war
halt ganz wichtig dass das polster so
ein bisschen nach gibt aber auch nicht
zu sehr
und das ist eben ein polster ist was ezb
ist jetzt graue das ist neutral ist und
grau passt super zu steinwand und ganz
wichtig weil mir auch die sitztiefe da
empfehle ich euch auch mal drauf zu
achten müssen jetzt 55 zentimeter hier
in der tiefe und das ist für mich immer
am bequemsten ist natürlich auch
geschmackssache
mein couchtisch ist auch von wave eine
oberfläche haben jetzt die bildreiche
und die füße sind aus metall die füße
passen wunderbar mit der couch zusammen
und die eiche moment wir gehen mal drei
schritte zurück sind jetzt in der küche
und die passt eben hier total auf die
arbeitsplatte und es passt wie die faust
aufs auge obwohl die platte hier von
schreiner ist und die von wafer und wenn
man reinkommt denkt man das passt so
zusammen und ich zeige euch hier auch
direkt meine barhocker weil auch ganz
ganz viele nachgefragt habe ich schon
etwas länger die habe ich ebenfalls zum
wave er und hier war mir halt ganz
wichtig dass man sich drehen kann man
das nach oben und unten verschieben kann
und daher mit dem grau finde ich ja auch
optimal jetzt stetigkeit auf der anderen
seite ich komme gerade vom flur hier ist
die küchentheke hier ist quasi der
wohnbereich und mir ganz wichtig dass
die couch eben nicht zu lang ist dass
das komplett ab schlief und nicht länger
ist als eben diese küchentheke und daher
musste ich ganz genau auf die maße
achten ebenso beim couchtisch bei das
hier meine lieben ist der einzige
durchgang
quasi hier an der küche und im
wohnzimmer vorbei
[Musik]
und was sagt ihr schreibt mir doch eure
meinung zu den möbeln die ich mir da
bestellt habe in die kommentare wie
findet ihr das die kombi findet ihr auch
dass es so gut zusammenfasst und ich
werde euch auf jeden fall noch einmal in
einem speziellen sonder video mitnehmen
wie ich hier das ganze nochmal schmücke
also im sinne von dekoriere da habe ich
auch jemand ganz besonderer meiner seite
aber ich verrate noch nicht zu viel das
ist eine spezielle sonder video und ich
glaube dass wir durch auch mega mega
mega gefallen jetzt habe ich kaffee
infos und jetzt geht es nicht gut und
deshalb ist hier einiges zu tun heute
ganz viel am pc schriftliche sachen e
mails und aufträge also sachen die ich
halt abarbeiten muss und das mache ich
jetzt hier ganz entspannt und es dauert
jetzt einige stunden und mal sehen und
sich dann heute noch so machen also
dieser tag wird sehr spontan heute ich
will eigentlich ganz ganz ganz viel
erledigen haben die shop aktion gehabt
da gab es eine aktion weil wir auf
instagram 10.000 abonnenten auch der
shop fertige geknackt haben nachdem
haben so nicht was mega tolles für euch
überlegt aber die aktion ist vorbei und
wenn ich es sehe ist ja dass uns
irgendwann mal wieder was einfallen und
da kam so viele bestellungen und unserer
mitarbeiter hat seine stunden komplett
gearbeitet für heute der macht welche
amt und da überlege ich dass ich gleich
hingehe und auch ein bisschen verpacke
damit die pakete auch schneller ankommen
[Musik]
vier stunden später und noch zwei leute
in zweiter ich habe zwei und ein hund
morgens schon drei auf jeden fall hat
haben wir jetzt was zu tun es gibt
besondere neuigkeiten beziehen mit
unserem lagerung wir vergrößern und
daher ist in den nächsten tagen so der
umzug geplant haben sie fährt jetzt in
einem lager weil das neue ware
eingetroffen ist setz mich aber vorher
im alten lager ab ich bin fertig vier
stunden sind vergangen es ist so heftig
wie schnell die zeit im moment vergeht
gerade hier im shop gibt es mal so
schnell vorbei denn immer nebenbei musik
und show you tube videos an und ja bald
ist der umzug oder freue ich mich schon
aber ich mache jetzt feierabend draußen
ist bestimmt schon dunkel der haben so
holt nicht gleich updates glaube ich
auch schon fertig mit seiner
erledigungen und dann müssen wir mal
schauen nämlich nämlich auch gar nichts
gegessen heute und ich habe auch gar
nichts gekommen also ich wollte noch mal
sagen es kommt bei mir auch mal vor dass
ich nichts versprochen
dann können wir uns halt auch mal
draußen was lecker nur weil man jetzt
food blogger ist oder kuba wie man so
schön sagt heißt ja nicht dass man jeden
tag kocht also da geht es mir genauso
wie schaffe ich es einfach nicht
wenn ich schneide ich muss auch zu sehen
sein müssen stattdessen erledigen
und dass man eigentlich messen
[Musik]
ende
hier in der stadt essen also in essen
mitarbeiter
das ist das allerbeste mittag für weiße
schuhe vor die kamera hat recht herzlich
mit super
wiesbaden
aber das wenige streich so die sache ist
erledigt hat nur zwei gedauert erwarten
kann sie müssen kurz einem kollegen
etwas geben das richtig eigentlich und
essen
die belichtung schlechter im handel
napoli
schön afghanistan liebe die aufgaben
bisher
[Applaus]
[Musik]
richtig in die ganze bezahlt hätten ganz
spontan zum bäcker platz zu sein
einkaufszentrum in das einkaufscenter
ist jeden ersten freitag im monat bis no
work wir haben's mitteln 18
für 14 da haben wir gedacht macht man
abstriche wenn ich schon in der schüssel
außerdem brauche ich eine neue
übergangsjacke also die passend
vielleicht finde ich ja sogar ein poster
übrigens gezwungenermaßen den sehr
kontrovers hinein gelb und beige passt
überhaupt nicht zusammen aber egal
hauptsache ich friere menschen hand
nehmen die sie ihr kind zum auto
gebracht dass ich mal von euch wieder
diesen familien treffen mit euch ist
echter fähig
einen ganz spannenden einkauf gemacht
unterhemden dieser prozent gekauft und
haben sich unter helfen gekauft um mega
spannend und ich liebe bücher ich liebe
bruch leben ich könnte hier eigentlich
meine ganzen tag verbringen aber der
hund im buchladen von in der stadt des
sexy so schlimm ich habe mein mann
verloren ist es offiziell habe ihn
verlor sitzt schon wie konnte es soweit
kommen ich weiß noch auf instagram habt
ihr mich noch gewarnt wenn er das kauft
dann ist vorbei dann gibt es keine
gemeinsamen haben werden ja stimmt noch
nicht
na ja ich gehe ins bett wir sehen uns
morgen wieder tief bis morgen
guten morgen ich auf ersten schöneren
start in den tag dann gibt es halt brot
mit käse auch gut ein paar vitamine habe
ich gefrühstückt jetzt muss ich
einkaufen gehen ich vermeide es
eigentlich samstags einkaufen zu gehen
weil es in dem man immer sehr sehr viele
kunden und wenn man hat die möglichkeit
innerhalb der woche morgens einkaufen zu
gehen total gerne aber ich kam diese
woche nicht dazu und deshalb schreibe
ich mir ist auch und dann geht's nach zu
kaufland soll los geht's also manche
wege kann ich mir einfach nicht merken
dass ich trotzdem das navi ich kenne
eigentlich den weg aber irgendwie
brauche ich das mittag und die liste
habe ich auch schon geschrieben ich mach
mal eine einkaufsliste übrigens immer so
hier ist der eingang vom laden also hier
geht's direkt bei kaufland los mit obst
und so weiter dann gibt es in die back
abteilungen dann in die abteilung und
dann noch konserven und schokolade und
so mache ich meine einkaufsliste dann
immer wenn man vergesse ich auch nichts
und dann ist das auch schön
chronologisch sortiert ich hätte die tür
auf meinem vater und ich denke warum ist
das so luftig die hintere tür die stadt
einfach offen zu gemacht
[Musik]
einkauf erledigt jetzt habe ich die
einkäufe weggeräumt die sind schon mal
erledigt jetzt muss ich mal langsam was
kochen ich war ziemlich lang aber
kaufland ist schon meine zwei stunden
verbracht schon heftig aber man
großeinkauf noch das dauert ein bisschen
länger und wenn ich alleine wird dann
schlendern ich immer so viel und dann
suche ich mir immer so sachen außen bis
zehn mal zehn jahre lang die verpackung
durch ich habe noch lange da hätte
nämlich lang gekauft für oh mein gott
was habe ich euch noch gar nicht erzählt
mein gott moment davon muss ich mich
kurz hinsetzen ich hasse könig erzählt
oh mein gott eine kurze unterbrechung
ich lasse alles stehen und liegen weil
ich euch das neueste vom neuesten man
ich erzählt habe
ich war vorgestern also bevor man blog
anfing beim wdr ich im fernseher und
zwar live heute live könnt ihr euch das
vorstellen kann wie vieles schief gehen
kann und wie man sich ob klappern kann
und irgendwas gibt daneben und ist
einfach live also zwar richtig
angekommen
ich erzähle den leuten vom wdr bis haben
sie komplett tillich weiter
also mega mega die geile erfahrung
megageil erfahrung und es hat alles
super hingehauen aus
datenschutzrechtlichen gründen kann ich
euch die sendung ziemlich einfügen nicht
mehr ausschnitte davon aber ist das
mache es ist ja in der mediathek und das
den link werde ich euch unten einfügen
bock habt dann schaut euch die sendung
an das war bei hier und heute im wdr
und ich war dafür das thema grillen
international und das thema türkei und
daher wurde ich eingeladen da meinen
alltag überzugehen und mein alternative
ich noch ziemlich stolz das rezept denn
auch ich habe sehr viel recherchiert ich
habe voll neugierig bin betörten gefragt
wie die das machen also im restaurant
meine ich damit
und er habe immer geguckt habe mehr hat
mir so richtig habe mir das so die die
information richtig eingesogen im
eigentlichen damit ist authentisch wie
möglich ist dann hätte ich das rezept
einem herausgebracht mega stolz und habe
auch ganz viel positives feedback
bekommen das ist total authentisch ist
das rezept und das tut sich im fernsehen
vorstellen könnte das wollte ich war so
aufgeregt aber ich hab es auch echt ganz
gut gemeistert muss ich sagen sind nicht
vergehen begangen das fleisch gut
geschmeckt und hammer einfach richtig
hammer und das team war auch super
netto sympathische menschen hier haben
liga haben sich zieht so brauchte ich
bekomme ich bin schon gefährlich wird
erzählen dann haben sie aber auch voll
geduldig die ganze zeit der hat die
ganze fülle geduldig daneben gestanden
und so weil die sendungen gegen eine
stunde 45 da war ich ab und zu mal live
in der schalte und am ende sogar ganz
zwölf minuten live und da haben sie ganz
hinter nehmen hat mir auch ein zu kaffee
gebracht und so ich toll bist ja immer
komm doch mal kommen wir die kamera ist
nicht schlimm dass dem belchen pyjama an
haarteil sprachen konnten so schlimm
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
grüße dich auf na ja umsonst ansa die
geht so mein block läuft jetzt schon so
ich hab schon tag internieren
du bist ja so kaum zu sehen wo man den
mund nie gesehen habe ich es nie
gekommen zu sein nur wieder gedreht
ja weil ich weiß ich hab mir nie das
reingezogen zu regnen würde ich dort auf
das war echt toll
also ich viel spaß gemacht ist echt
professor gemacht er hat so viel
geschrieben werden sondern dass man muss
ja auch sagen wir haben das war überall
auf instagram voll aktiv wir haben
hinter den kulissen immer aufgabe ist
können wir euch jetzt hier einblenden
und das war halt mega die anteilnahme
leute die das support er soll so heftig
wie ihr euch gefreut hatte mir feedback
da gegangen dass sie das toll findet
dass leute extra fernseher eingeschaltet
haben weil wir darin und die sagen milde
und gepflegt und für dich habe ich mir
daher eingestellt fand schon mega jetzt
geht weiter haben sie ab ins
arbeitszimmer ist jetzt doch kein land
machen heute doch vegetarische nudeln
irgendwelche nudeln irgendwas es schnell
geht dann müssen wir es noch mal in den
shop
[Musik]
ich muss mir schön die block kamera
holen
unsere echtes pakete unsere stimmung
kammern weil im letzten block hatten wir
aber es so trainingsanzüge besteht und
schaut mal müsst ihr das allerbeste hat
eigentlich haben wir bestellt
man sieht jetzt in der kamera nicht so
ich muss den akku aufladen der geht im
moment leer und dann zeige ich euch das
mal im spiegel
aber ich finde dass sich das behalten
sollte steht um die über sein spiel
du bist mein akkus jetzt leider leer
gegangen so so ist der nächste tag
[Musik]
ja das ist auch schön aber auch wie
wenig so schön egal hauptsache ich kann
dir klar unsere motivation muss ich das
auch für kuchen bot das sieht ein
genialer apfelkuchen der einfach nur
normal lecker schmeckt und manch habt
ihr nämlich schon vorab schon mal
ausprobiert ich bin am spitzenleute das
ist echt war mit dem gefühl ich kann
solche daten sollte draußen 24 grad ist
eigentlich relativ kühl
aber naja damit den kuchen in den ofen
geschoben wo 27 deswegen schütze ich so
und die 3 grad
gaddafi war mit sie kuchen den ofen
geschoben und überlegen jetzt noch etwas
zu drehen ja ich überlege gerade unser
mittagessen abzufüllen da kann ich euch
aber hier nicht mitnehmen wir meiner
mittagessen zubereiten was macht denn
nächstes jahr auf youtube das nächste
video im kasten ja jetzt konnte ich
natürlich nicht mitnehmen weil ich sitze
dann auf youtube
aber ich muss das z fertig machen
[Musik]
also so sieht erstmal aus natürlich
sieht sie in der richtigen kamera noch
mal ganz anders aus erzählt er hier die
ränder von diesem brett ja wenn das
stück gleich drauf kommt kommt hier
natürlich auf dem teller auch noch mal
ein bisschen farbe und seht ihr jetzt
dieses harmonische spiel zwischen diesen
beiden farben
[Musik]
guck mal youtube live youtube live
ich habe so hunger habe ich schon
erwähnt welches so einen abnormalen
hunger oder weiß so recht zu schätzen
dass wir ein kinder zum essen könnten
wenn wir wollen ich habe zeit neue stadt
nichts mehr gegessen haben sie jetzt
auch gleich fertig und dann können wir
endlich kommt tsunami ja das ist doch
jetzt schöne belohnung heute sollte
jetzt gerade so einen toten punkt kennt
ihr das nach dem essen vollen punkt
gehabt hab ich erstmal im schlafzimmer
20 minuten hingelegt wir haben 1948 ich
muss noch ein rezept entwickelt wir für
kaufland das wird ein mega rezept aber
ich muss es unbedingt einmal vorher
ausprobieren weil das was mit hefeteig
ist und ich will dass du perfekt ist ich
will einfach dieses rezept einfach
perfekt haben und daher für mich dass es
nicht auf anhieb haben sie hat in der
zwischenzeit ein super interessantes als
tv video hochgeladen
ich würde mal sagen ich werde es euch in
der infobox verlinken dann könnt ihr
euch das ansehen das hat mit dem thema
schwangerschaft zu tun
was tun
ich bin schwanger ihr könnt euch raus
ich gerne mal ansehen
ein statement von hamza was ich so
unterschreiben kann
schaut euch gerne mal an und
unterschreibt das formular und ich mache
jetzt meine zutaten bereit für mein
rezept wirke die nicht muss gehen
woher die drogen die kadetten gekommen
kostet ihn erst in 60 160 und dort den
sich prinz hätte mir der größten stadt
80 71 18
ja ich gehe auf die wissenschaft solche
wenn ihr zu schaffen und einfach hier
ist das unordentliche was ist los
das auf und ab bis sie zum shop im shop
bankhäuser paket genau dann wünsch euch
noch nicht einen abend nicht machen
nachtschicht und wir machen jetzt ein um
einen teig geht jetzt und ich kann ja
erst in der 3 4 stunde weiter machen
daher schnappe ich mir jetzt noch mein
kaffee und 70 auf die couch genau ich
wollte euch auch zeigen was ich mir bei
ipsos bestellt habe und zwar hatte ich
mir so ein trainingsanzug besser gesagt
sein anzug zum zuhause chillen bestellt
sind die farbe so genial ja so ein
zweiteiler mit streifen und der passt
auf passform ist perfekt und finde ihn
richtig schöne einige grad frischer
zeigen kann was ich genau bei airbus
bestellt im letzten block hatte ich ja
bestellt und mehr haben auch gar nicht
bestellt das war es auch schon jetzt
muss ich wieder ausziehen bei essen ist
es voll war und zweitens muss es erstmal
in die wäscherei einmal wieder umziehen
ich müsste jetzt eigentlich auf freuen
aber ich bin so müde heute das gibt es
gar nicht trägt jetzt noch mein café zu
ende die paar minuten chill noch 100
danach ich den rest fertig und ich
glaube viel mehr passiert heute auch
nicht und dann kann ich den blog ja
eigentlich beenden an der stelle und
schneiden damit die autos schnell wie
möglich material habt ihr euch ansehen
könnt was ich so gemacht habe und
fabriziert habe und dann beginne ich
auch schon demnächst ja ich hoffe
natürlich dass euch die blogs gefallen
ihr könnt mir gerne feedback der beim
letzten mal gab es auch feedback das ich
mehr zeigen soll und nicht nur sagen
soll was ich gemacht habe ich hoffe dass
wir das dass ich das hier so gut es geht
berücksichtigt habe und euch das
natürlich gefällt es sollte außerdem
noch ein video demnächst online kommen
wo haben sie und ich so ein bisschen
fragen beantworten ein faq und ich finde
das ist jetzt die beste möglichkeit euch
zu fragen was möchtet ihr wissen gerade
von euch interessant zu wissen was ihr
beantwortet haben möchte tim effekt
schreibt mir hier ein standard fragen
kommen vor
vielleicht gerne mal so ausgefallene
fragen vielleicht gerne mal
philosophische fragen mag ich auch total
gerne ja also die gleiche standard
fragen kommen vor
diese klassischen fragen wie alt und wie
habt euch kennengelernt was habt ihr
studiert und solche sachen also macht
sich darüber keine sorgen und ganz viele
fragen auf wie heißt du denn echt leute
ich heiße kiki ist es so einfach wie es
ist der einfachste einfachste name der
welt ich wünsche euch jetzt einen
wunderschönen tag ich freue mich sehr
auf eure kommentare hinterlasst auf
jeden fall diesen block ein like dann
sehe ich auf der euch gefallen hat oder
nicht das ist für mich auch immer so
wichtig zu wissen und bleibt weiterhin
so aktiv bei unseren videos ist das
youtuber davon leben dass sie aktiv seit
der blöde algorithmus ich sage einfach
so der algorithmus ist einfach so ein
gerade bei rezepten ist es so schwierig
weil ich weiss man schaltet eben nicht
immer ein mann sie dem titel was mit
spinat mag ich nicht schuldig nicht ein
ich weiß wie das ist wenn ihr trotzdem
kurz einschaltet oder kommentar da
gesagt okay ich mag nicht so gern egal
ich schalte nächsten mal wieder ein
irgendwas dass das tut schon so gut das
ist einfach so ein push für den
algorithmus ich habe auch echt das
problem dass viele moment schreibe ich
bekomme es ist einfach nicht angezählt
und ich habe das häkchen drin dass meine
abonnenten benachrichtigt werde und sie
werden einfach nicht benachrichtigt das
ärgert mich so steckt so viel fleiß
dahinter und man ärgert einen da ist
umso mehr wenn alles für die katz ist es
ist ja nicht alles für die katz ich ich
übertreibe jetzt vielleicht ein bisschen
aber es ist schon ein bisschen schade
das ist nicht angezeigt wird ich finde
das total schade ich achten bei jedem
video druck dass das häkchen drin ist
dass ihr benachrichtigt werden
naja darüber schreibt mir gerne mal in
die kommentare was wir gerne beim effekt
sehen möchtet oder generell zum brocken
und so ein bisschen austauschen und dann
wünsche ich euch ein wunder wunder
wunderschönen tag und wir sehen uns dann
alle spätestens beim nächsten rezept
oder im nächsten block und den block vom
letzten mal habe ich euch auch in die
infobox verlinkt könnte auch gerne mal
rein schon okay macht's gut in event vor
leute bevor ich euch gehen lasse gondel
läuft gangl das ist so ein genialer film
ich auf den zweimal auf deutschland
einmal original auf englisch gesehen
absolute empfehlung schaut euch an wenn
ihr zeit habt natürlich nicht jetzt ist
es schon vorbei wenn ihr das seht aber
ich glaube den gibt es auch bei auf
netflix oder sogar auf amazon also
absolut empfehlen
ja das hat spaß gemacht
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
die hose und gewaschen weil du bist aber
du hast draußen damit ich hab's recht
wollen die zeit mein anzug und ich hoffe
die zuschauer hier wäre sollten wir uns
vorher nachher bekloppt geworden stellt
diesem punkt hätte sicherlich gegeben
punkt wenn du einfach nur müde bist du
willst du keine verabschiede ich mich
heute danke euch da sein dafür dass
eigentlich hat und das sicherlich so
etwas bestimmt
das ist die bestellung allem also weiter
aber das kriegen wir wohl nicht mehr
zuhause ist mein bruder gesagt
bis zum nächsten blog eine goethe
schiller
ich weiß ob sie dem ok